so thanks of the organizers for the
invitation very happy to be here and
I'll spend the next half an hour telling
you about a new project I have as you
see else with some of my PhD students
and a postdoc Martin Sammartino who was
here for for a month couple of months
ago learning and what I'm gonna do for
the first 10 minutes or so is its kind
of describe to you the most well-known
automata learning algorithm called L
star but before I start let me make some
distinction about what I'm gonna be
talking about which is called active
learning and something that is also very
popular in the literature at the moment
which is called passive learning so the
idea behind active learning is that you
have a system a black box system and you
can query it actively so you can ask at
any step you can ask any question about
membership the idea behind passive
learning and there are various
algorithms for passive learning is that
you record the behavior of the system
for a couple of days or hours or
whatever you have a look and then you
try from the law to infer a model that
approximates what the system does so for
the rest of the talk when I mentioned
learning I always mean active learning
and active learning started back in in
the 80s with this paper by Dana Angwin
called learning regular sets from
queries and counter examples and she
described a logarithm in in that paper
that is nowadays referred to as as L
star algorithm in that paper she looked
at regular languages and she looked at
the problem of learning a mini-mall
deterministic automaton that accepts a
certain regular language and you might
think that this is kind of lame because
regular languages are so simple but the
reality is that the algorithm itself is
is also very simple which makes it very
beautiful in my opinion
but it turns out it's also very powerful
so everyone's algorithm was used in
mainland linguistics for many years and
in the last I would say ten years eight
to ten years it was rediscovered in
computer science in the context of
verification and even though it's only
about regular languages in deterministic
automaton people managed to use Angwin
Zog written to actually verify protocols
running in the bank cards and passports
and and so on and drivers and Printers
so you know the fact that it's simple
does not mean you cannot actually do
real verification tasks with it so
here's I'm gonna show you L star by
example and the setup is as follows and
this is kind of the same setup for any
active learning algorithm there is
entity called the teacher to whom you
can ask questions and you and there's a
black box system that you you want to
learn and this teacher knows about what
the system does and what you're going to
build you're going to build an automaton
model of the system so you see some does
more than regular queries what you're
going to build this kind of an
approximation of the regular part and
what you can ask the teacher are two
types of queries one called membership
queries and basically you can ask is a
certain word in the language and the
other one is an equivalent speery so at
some point you ask a bunch of questions
and then you convince yourself you know
what the language is and you can ask the
teacher is my hypothesis actually the
language that is running in the system
and the teacher will either say yes or
it will say no and give you back a
counter example so this setup of having
a teacher is an ideal setup and as you
can imagine in actual verification tasks
you won't have a teacher I mean it's a
black box system you don't know what's
running in there so membership queries
are easy to implement equivalence
queries are not so easy to implement so
what happens with the conspiracy in a
lot of the implementations of L star
that actually are doing very
is that you kind of approximate your
equivalents query by exhaustive testing
so you kind of say okay if I query the
system up to a certain length and it's
matching what I my hypothesis I will say
it's okay otherwise you won't find a
counter example and that's what you give
back so the algorithm builds not really
an automaton directly but it builds so
called observation table that is
basically a table that gathers all the
membership queries you've done so far so
the idea is you have this table which is
indexed by a set of words both on the
rosen and the columns and every 0 and 1
that you see here on the table is
basically populated with a membership
query to the teacher and it will have a
1 if and only if the word that you can
obtain from concatenating the row index
with the column index is in the language
so here's here's an example of a table
and how you would build an automaton
from the table so basically the basic
idea of this tables is that the rows
themselves will be the state of your
automaton and the transitions in the
automaton are obtained by adding an
extra letter to the row index that you
see here so like here q0 is the row of
the empty word and with an EI i go to q1
which is the row of a and with another a
I go to the row of a a so this automaton
has three states because those are the
three rules that we see here and they
are the only three distinct roles in the
whole table I'll give you a more simple
example in a moment but this is just to
show that from a table you can build an
automaton
by taking States the rows as final
States any row that has a 1 in the
column for the empty word so here you
start seeing I'm making some assumptions
in particular I assume that the empty
word is always a column index otherwise
this would not be
the initial state is the row of the
empty word yet another assumption I'm
assuming the empty word is also a row
index and the way I will build this
table is basically by staying by
starting from the empty word and then
increasing the length of the words and
asking more and more queries and then
the transition function as I said before
you take a row and you take a letter and
you return the row index by the word you
had before concatenated with this letter
now you might wonder is this really
well-defined because I'm hand-waving a
little bit well it is well-defined as
long as the table has a certain shape
and here's the shape I need a table to
have I need the table so table is just a
function of this coin for s and E set of
words and I need the table to fulfill
two conditions one condition is it
should be closed meaning that if I look
at the lower part of the table so I will
always throw the table with a wine in
the middle which basically I have a
let's a relevant set of words here and
then I have those words plus one letter
continuation here below which is kind of
a one letter look ahead and so if I look
at the lower part of the tables if I
take one letter more than my say
relevant set of words then that row I
obtained there brings nothing new so
there's already a row in the upper part
of the table that contains the
information I need the other condition
is I ask the table to be consistent
namely if two rows were the same in the
upper part then they should be the same
after I take any one step and this
basically these two conditions guarantee
that the transition function is well
defined so first this condition
guarantees that actually the target
state here row of is a is actually a
state
because the set of states only contains
rows that are in the upper part of the
table
the second condition basically says that
the choice of representative I'm making
here is relevant so no matter what I
choose as the s here it doesn't matter
so if two rows were the same they will
still be the same here okay so let's um
let's now go to the algorithm and see
what you really build so let's take a
very simple language namely the language
of actually let's over the instantiate a
let's take this language towards a a b b
this kind of very lame example how many
states do i need to accept this language
rather you want to guess does anyone
[Music]
know how many states will it take to
actually draw an automaton to accept
this language so actually it's a very
simple language it only has two words
but if you wanna draw a deterministic
automaton that accepts it
you need five states so it's not it's
not such a simple example indian and if
you Lilla straight all steps of the
algorithm basically the algorithm starts
as follows it says okay let's ask the
teacher what happens with the empty word
so we ask the teacher what happens with
the empty word then the teacher says
zero because the empty word is not in l1
and then at the same time we always
extend the table we do one more step so
we ask about a and about P so I'm
assuming my alphabet only has letters in
D so at this stage we say ah I think I
know what the language is namely it's
the language that accepts no words and
at this stage making and hypothesis is
okay because my table is closed if I
check if the table is it's closed and
consistent it will be so it is closed
because the only row I have here is the
row with 0 and in the lower part as well
and then it still seems consistent
because I actually only have one row in
the upper
part of the table so I don't need to
check anything for consistency so at
this stage I make the conjecture that
the language that I'm trying to accept
is the empty language and the teacher
will say no because a a should be in the
language and it's not in the language
you gave me then what do I do
so the algorithm tells me if the teacher
requires no gives you a counter example
T and you should extend your relevant
words with T and all its prefixes so the
algorithm makes no assumption about the
length of the counter example so the
teacher could give you any counter
example in this case there's only two
that you can give so at this stage we
build the larger table so we make a few
more queries and we have now a new table
and this table is closed because I have
the only two rows I can see which is
with 0 and 1 but it's not consistent
because now the row for the empty word
and the row for the letter A are equal
but after 1 a step they are different so
this stage we need to fix this so the
table is not consistent so it's not good
enough to make conjecture so how do we
fix it so the algorithm says ok if it's
not consistent because you've observed a
difference after one step then just add
this difference to the table by
increasing the column indexes so I saw a
difference after one a so I basically
extend here things with an A so now I
have here the value for a a and here the
value for a so now the row for epsilon
and a are different so they don't play
anymore
any role in consistency checking so at
this stage I again have a table that is
closed and it's also consistent so at
this stage I can make another conjecture
namely that this is the language and it
starts to look a bit more interesting
but the teacher says
so bad because BB so BB stays here it's
rejected by your automaton but it's in
the language so you need to fix that so
you go on and you do a few more more
fixes so we had a few so the counter
example was BB so we have the Roby and
BB we film in this table we add the one
step extensions and now the table is
still closed but again it's not
consistent they cause the row for the
empty word again and B are the same but
after one big step they are different so
in the same way as before we need to add
one more column and now I make another
conjecture and I ask the teacher and the
teacher says you're almost there but ba
BB is still wrong so let's see B a is
accepted and it should not be do you see
the counter examples can go both ways so
you can get words that should be there
and what the children people so you do
one more step and after one more step
which I'm not showing here you actually
arrive to the right automata this
automaton is the minimal automaton that
accepts this language and the operation
is done in a way that you always keep
the automaton minimal for every
hypothesis you make and that's crucial
for termination because otherwise I
could be adding states that are
completely useless from the algorithmic
never sorry I didn't understand it's how
you made the conjecture from the table
because you couldn't be other
conjectures
so I by definition from a close and
consistent table I build an automaton
that accepts the same language as this
table is consistent with and language
disorder the automaton is built in the
following way the states are the rows of
the of the table also actually of the
upper part of the table the transitions
are given by the one letter extensions
of the row indexes and the final states
are all the ones that have a one in the
ones at home so this will not be minimal
I mean you make a conjecture that is
still consistent with the table but if
it's fully consistent it accepts the
same language right and then either it's
the same automaton or it's not well it's
not minimal so the way you keep
minimality is by observing that these
rooms they really denote all the Myhill
narrowed equivalence classes of your
language I'll start by example and
there's lots of papers out there where
with applications and also some
generalizations to milling machines and
Iowa tomato and a few more things but so
this is where things were till two years
ago and the thing is people realize that
finite alphabets are are not enough in
some applications and so we started
wondering if we could extend L star for
infinite alphabets and and how would
that work so let me kind of just
illustrate what what this means and
where the challenge really is so if you
take this language that we use this
running example and you now assume that
your alphabet is infinite then language
will be infinite
so an automaton accepting this language
will will have to have an infinite
number of states and if you stare at it
for a while you will realize that well
it is infinite but in fact you could
come up with a finite representation as
long as you allow certain variables in
the states namely in this middle zone
here of your pollutant all these states
here are somehow doing the same for a
certain if you fix the letter there have
an X there and in fact what you do in
the next step is fully determined so
this idea of equipping the automaton
with say a couple of registers has also
been out there in the literature and it
kind of increases the amount of examples
that you can cover so the goal to try to
not to learn this type of automata so
this is well there's many ways to
formalize what this automata really are
but what I'm gonna use in this in this
talk is what we called nominal automata
so I think many of you in the audience
have seen this phenomenal sets were
rediscovered in computer science by and
if it's and jamika by when they were
studying mathematical an elegant
mathematical framework to deal with all
the equivalence and named binding in the
semantics of programming languages and
the idea I mean nominal setting and sort
of a nutshell are infinite sets with
symmetries so they are infinite but they
actually are finitely representable
which makes them amenable to kind of
have these finite representations like I
showed in the previous slide and also
one more in the next slide and so
normally on sets were kind of there in
this work of kabayan pits and then a few
years ago on this group of people from
Warsaw started looking at automata
theory over nominal set so take
I'm at the theory book and Replace have
reset by a nominal set and that's the
question which theorems are still valid
so they have a series of papers on
developing automata theory over normal
sense so going back to that example or a
similar example to that one I had a
couple of slides ago consider the
language of words where a certain letter
occurs twice in the world so how would
you accept how would you build an
automaton that accepts this language if
the alphabet is infinite one way to do
it would be to say start from from s0
from from some initial state read
letters so a here is kind of a symbolic
representation this can be any letter so
it's not only later a but kind of redo
it and then at some point you make a
guess that the next letter you're
reading in s0
is actually the letter that's going to
occur twice in your word make this guess
and at this stage you are in a state
where you know that you can only accept
if you see a again when you see a a
second time you accept so again we see
this kind of structure that is infinite
I mean this this pink area here in the
middle is an infinite number of states
but there's a pattern so you can kind of
write this down as a finite
representation where this middle state
has this this kind of variable that you
can change the name and as long as you
do it modulo changing transitions as
well this all will work out and will be
an acceptor for this language so
formally what this is here you have
three states in fact you have three
orbits of states so the initial and the
final state are kind of the single state
orbit and this middle stayed here is
really standing for the whole so there's
kind of one state for each so it's an
infinite number of states there's one
state for each letter in the alphabet
and your
however modulo permutations the
transition function is closed under the
permutation so this is what is called
equivariance and that's what kind of
kind of the core behind the fact that
you can represent this in a finite way
so this talk is basically I want to show
you how to generalize YoungStar
phenomena automata and the way we
developed these operate modes using
category theory and calls by one show
mod I will not be showing much of that
just a little bit and we could have done
that so in the literature you will find
other types of automata that could be
used to induce finite representations
for the languages I've shown namely what
is called register automata or fresh
register automata and the reason why we
decided to go with the definition of
Mikoyan and others is that nominal
automata as they are presented by the
Polish crowd are just automata in the
category of nominal sets so in fact what
I want to argue and this goes back also
to a comment that was made during the
discussion yesterday is that a
categorical approach to understanding
algorithms is not only useful to
understand why not written is correct
but it's also useful to generalize
algorithms to other structures so in
this case what we did and I'll show in a
second
looks very trivial once you've
understood the correctness of the
algorithm using category theory and then
it's just just it concludes a change of
pace category and this is what I think
perfect likes to call the one the X norm
X research program so the real title of
this talk is really one directional X
applied to the elf star
so this is what I should also next
appears in our purple paper of this of
next year and a lot of the categorical
background was developed in the note I
wrote for the Prakash Fest
with bar chuckles so paper algorithm as
it was and wonder if you apply the
boi-ing approach what would you have to
change to make this work in nominal sets
so you replace every set by nominal set
and then you stare so the first thing is
the table so the row and column indexes
are now infinite sets it's kind of the
weakness is that you need to find to
solve the fact that the table is not
close or consistent again can you know
might require that you check an infinite
amount of of rows and the other example
you get from the teacher so we're still
assuming the teacher is a very concrete
entity so you get a concrete counter
example with concrete letters so not
symbolic so T is a finite word so if you
only have finite prefixes so this means
that you are I'm gonna build the way you
are extending your s it's not really
good enough because you need to build an
infinite state space but the way you are
extending it seems to only generate
finitely many new rules so there's a few
things here that don't seem to be
working and we know first for that
language a abbc C and so on that no
finite automaton accepted so this this
will just not product however here's
what saves the day is that because we
are working in a nominal set we know
that actually those infinite sets s and
s extended with a and in admit a finite
representation of two permutations so
even though they are infinite sets they
are orbit finite
and the table the function Rho is
equivariance so it's it will be the same
modulo the permutation so this means
that the table itself should also admit
a finite symbolic representation that
operates only on a finite number of
orbits so in fact the algorithm after
you stir it for a while you realize that
you can fix the algorithm by only
changing three lines one when you extend
s you do not extend s with one word but
you extend it with the orbit generated
by that word so the word was all the
words that you can obtain by applying
permutations same thing for the poem and
think same thing for the counter example
so it seems that only three lines
changed and this is all very easy and
that's great but it's not really it's
not really as trivial as I'm trying to
make it look because as I said you
change the base category right so all
definitions need now to be talking about
orbit finite set instead of finite set
and these in principle means you need to
reprove correctness and termination and
all the theorems that Angwin had in her
paper so have we really saved any work
and this is where category theory comes
and where things become simpler by using
these techniques we develop them in the
paper that we have for precautious six
years birthday so the observation is
that the definitions of flows and
consistent which are kind of the crucial
definitions in a gwin's original paper
can be written and it has the details of
really matter but they can be written in
a certain diagrammatical form that after
you look at it for a while we realized
that the requirements
these definitions are really only the
fact that you have a category where you
have epi mono factorizations and not
only you can first of all you you
observe once you draw these pictures in
this way the first thing that to me was
striking is that you can really see that
closeness and consistency are dual
concepts you can really see that from
the diagram and the second thing is you
reduce your assumptions to a very kind
of general condition so this Emily
factorization is something that exists
in in many categories and why is this
useful is that
the moment you kind of come to terms
with the fact that this works you can
take s to be an orbit finite set I mean
you can you can transport these diagrams
to nominal sets and things just work so
the definitions are the same really the
same and more interestingly the proof of
correctness of the algorithm and
termination
so actually termination in Angwin
algorithm is really the proof of
correctness is also the same
and it's also reduced to kind of a
pretty butterfly diagram which again
works in in any reasonable category so
from that we have already observed in
2014 that you could learn a certain
version of weighted automata basically
by changing the base category to vector
spaces there was a paper from 2009 which
was not done categorically wasn't very
concretely
where they present an Angwin style
algorithm for an offense and in fact it
can be obtained from this categorical
perspective by replacing sets by joint
analysis you can also do a kind of
improvement on the allstar that is known
as reverse and shafir algorithm by
learning something called product
optimism all of these things that were
out there including our you know our
only perspective on things were we were
assuming the alphabet to be to be finite
symbol so once you move to normal
correctness is still easy because it's
just a diagram from a couple of slides
ago it's very easy to implement
variations because of the abstract
perspective and you can you can work in
in different data domains which means
you can implement even versions of time
delta motto but not everything is easy I
mean one thing one should not
underestimate is that the correctness
proof is the same but then once you try
to implement the actual algorithm you
need to represent all those infinite
structures in some finite way and so
when we started implementing the
algorithm we very quickly hittable I
mean it was really this was really the
tricky bit and the problem was there was
some sort of I mean we didn't really
have a good programming language with
nominal support black.we the Polish
crowd was already working very hard on
doing this if they even have two
programming languages not with nominal
support so we we teamed up with them and
use the algorithm a sort of a proof of
concept for one of their extensions of
high school and which meant
implementation was not very efficient
but one thing I would like to say which
was for us it was very neat so we had an
implementation in high school of the
original algorithm then we copied it and
pasted it to this Haskell nominal
Haskell extension which is called n
lambda and it was running it was
literally running copy and paste the
same code and again it's the same code
but the base you know the basic
computational model is different and it
was just running it was just not
efficient at all but it was running the
only thing that became that turned out
to be kind of the world and even after
we had some sort of support was that the
nominal language that Bartek developed
with his students was very targeted at
the nominal support and they kind of
forgot that to talk with the real world
you need concrete in create communicate
so you need concrete counter examples so
in the Popol paper we had to kind of
hack the concrete communication and by
now this has been fixed so actually
we've been using the algorithm and the
verification parks who want to do with
it as a sort of driving force to get n1
the library a step further and there's
also a C++ extension with nominal sets
which we in the meantime have
implemented logarithmic and surprisingly
it's not more efficient than in lambda
and this is of course probably due to
the fact that they haven't really
improved their library very much but
for now we're still sticking with the
hostel so I guess the message is that
this abstract perspective gives you some
guidance in developing algorithms but in
the end you still if you want to
implement them you still need to do some
work okay so I'm gonna think skip this
we are now actually using the algorithm
to learn real protocols and actual code
and this is kind of last week in this
week work so it's really ongoing work
and I'm just going to skip it
it's basically what we're trying and
this current work we want to test the
algorithm in actual protocols where this
nominal setting brings brings something
new so all so you know protocols in
which new names have to be generated
which are kind of pervasive in in crypto
seem to be kind of than the good testing
suite for this we have implemented in
the meantime communication complete
communication with real code so we're
really getting to a point where we will
be able to perform some verification
toast so maybe someone in the audience
here has some more examples that we
could more future work let me focus a
little bit on on this came to think of
my remark of Gordon with soul in the
audience and it actually I think
actually one of the neat theoretical
things that came out of the work so when
you're learning this de Soto Madame they
very quickly so we try it as examples in
our local paper we try to learn simple
data structures like FIFO buffers and
when you start learning FIFO buffers you
know you you hope you make it to five or
five and
because a couple of weeks to make it to
five four five so I mean you know you
could learn how to Omata that to
represent a fight for two very easily a
five four three but the moment we hit
five four three with the original
implementation we were stuck and that
was very disappointing I mean if you're
not submit a public paper with a five
four three because this is just say
something about your implementation that
you don't want the reviewers to know so
we we thought hard what was going on in
the algorithm that was kind of why was
it so inefficient and then we realize
that the tables we were building were
growing very very fast and most of the
time there was a lot of redundant
information in the table that we did not
want to have so we very quickly realized
that this was a phenomenon that is very
that we had seen namely take the
language of words where the fifth letter
from the right is an a this is an
example in most automatic books to show
that if you try to build a deterministic
automaton for this language you will
need at least 32 states but there's a
very obvious four six state
non-deterministic automaton that accepts
this language so we very quickly realize
that what we should be doing would be to
kind of be storing the table as an
undetermined a sort of non-deterministic
automaton and this would mean that we
could learn more languages and as we
were doing this and this this is already
in the literature for the original
starting point so other people have
observed this we realize that this
phenomenon of sort of 1/16
representation of languages is more
general than just non-deterministic
automata versus deterministic automata
actually you can do this for any moment
or let's say for a large class of
movements and in the case of nominal
automata what was very interesting is we
realized that a lot of the the table was
growing due to non determinism that's
one one point but also the other point
was that there was a lot of
redundant information that could be
compressed if you allow a sort of
substitution moment that is it is a sort
of introducing more awful equivalence
than you already have and again we
proved correctness of that concrete
example using the same techniques so we
now believe that there's a more general
theory out there to be discovered and
not only we believe we are pretty sure
because recently we discovered that the
argument money's already had the paper
from 74 where they argue a similar a
similar thing for a class of mono - so
that that's kind of one of exciting
whine of words that came out of it but
definitely real verification tasks and
the implementation is what's keeping the
students so that's it
[Applause]